my son sacrificed his life to save me  these powers  are not a gift  but a curse  born  out of rage  [Music]  this loose cannon needs to be locked  down  before innocent people start getting  hurt  he's been asleep for 5 000 years  you find us a cell that can hold them  we'll take care of the rest who's on the  team  i didn't bring a passport we don't need  passports  we're the justice society  black adam we're here to negotiate your  peaceful surrender  i'm not peaceful  nor do i surrender  here we go  i knew before no one  you didn't come here to seek justice  you came to exact revenge  [Music]  i never said i was a hero  [Music]  you believe you are not worthy  but fate does not make mistakes  [Music]  you have two paths  you can be the destroyer of this world  [Music]  or you can be its savior  you